[Music]
all signs seem to indicate the Megane
Markel is the one and with perry and
toronto her second home all eyes are on
the couple to see if they will make
public appearance who Prince was all
smiles during his first public event to
kick-off the Invictus games Megan was
not with him although she lives in
Toronto and it's where she films her USA
Network legal drama suits have you ever
tried to sleep with someone and then
retaliated ones they rejected you Harry
looked relaxed and happy as he met with
military families during the event the
games are an athletic competition for
wounded veterans it was created by Harry
who served in the British Army last year
he spoke at the games in Orlando but
what I learned through serving was that
the extraordinary privileges of being a
prince gave me the extraordinary
opportunity to help my military family
there has been lots of speculation that
Harry and Megan could make that first
official appearance as a couple at the
games but Kensington Palace would not
confirm or deny to ET if that would
happen during this week-long event and
in a strange twist ET is confirmed
Megan's ex-husband Trevor engleson is
producing a comedy pilot for Fox about a
man whose ex-wife marries a British
prince in the fictional pilot the ex
couple are forced to share custody of
their kids with the royal family
[Music]
you